The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
TONY PRESCOTT:
Great pleasure to be
in Woods Hole, my
first visit here,
had a wonderful swim
in the sea yesterday.
Sheffield Robotics is across
both universities in Sheffield.
And it's been
founded since 2011,
but we've really been doing
robotics since the 1980s.
And I joined them in 1989.
And we do pretty much every
different kind of robotics,
but I'm going to talk
about biomimetics.
I also do what you might
call cognitive robotics.
And I collaborate with
Giorgio Metta on that,
but since he's
speaking too, I'm going
to focus on the more
animal-like robots
that we've been developing.
So this is one of
our latest projects.
This is a small,
autonomous, mobile robot,
which is a commercial
platform, which
will be available in the
UK, I think, next January.
And there will hopefully
be a developer program
for people that are
interested in helping
to develop the intelligence
for this robot.
So this is at a conference we
had in Barcelona last month.
And you can see that
it's a robot pet.
And we've been
focusing on giving it
some effective
communication abilities,
responding
particularly to touch.
You can see that it's
orienting to stimuli.
It has stereo vision.
It has stereo sound.
And it can orient
to visual stimuli
and also to auditory stimuli.
Here we're showing it
a picture of itself
on this magazine cover.
And the goal is to
demonstrate that we can,
in a commercial robot that
will cost less than $1,000,
considerably less, some
of the principles of how
the brain generates behavior.
So this robot is called MiRo.
It is based on some high-level
principles abstracted
from what we know about how
mammalian brains control
behavior, so it's a
relatively complex robot, 13
degrees of freedom, 3 arm
processes corresponding
to different
levels, if you like,
of the neuroaxis, the
central nervous system.
So once you start out with some
general ideas, and questions,
and issues about
how we might learn
from the biology in the
brain, how to develop robots,
and how we might use robots to
help us understand the brain.
And a central question
I think that robotics
can help us answer, and I
think that's a core question
in neuroscience, is what
you might call the problem
of behavioral integration.
And the neuroscientist
Ernest Barrington
summarized this quite nicely.
He said, "the phenomenon
so characteristic of living
organisms, so very difficult
to analyze, the fact
that they behave as wholes
rather than as the sum
of their constituent parts.
Their behavior
shows integration,
a process unifying the
actions of an organism
into patterns that involve
the whole individual."
And this picture of a squirrel
over here I think nicely
demonstrates this.
So of course this squirrel
is leaping from one branch
to the next.
And you can see that
every part of his body
is coordinated and
organized for this action,
so you can see that his
eyes looking straight ahead,
his whiskers-- and I'll talk
a lot more about whiskers--
pointing forward.
His arms and his
feet are all ready
and they're there ready
to catch his fall.
Even his tail is
angled and positioned
to help him fly through the air.
So it's the coordination of the
different parts of the body,
and the multiple degrees
of freedom of the body,
and the sensory systems in space
and in time, which, I think,
is a critical problem
for biological control
and also a problem for robots,
which we're still struggling
to address with our robots.
And I want to give you two
very general principles
for thinking about how
brains solve this problem.
So many of you will have
come across Rodney Brooks,
yes, from MIT.
And he's famous
for, in robotics,
the notion of layered control,
which he called subsumption.
And I think the
ideas that he brought
into robotics really
changed how people thought
about robots in the 1980s.
But if we go back to the
1880s, John Hughlings Jackson,
who was a British neurologist,
proposed a similar idea,
but with respect to
the nervous system.
So in the 1880s, people
thought about the higher areas
of the brain,
particularly the cortex,
as being about higher thought,
and reasoning, and language,
and not so much about
perception and action.
And Hughlings Jackson, I think,
was revolutionary in his day
in saying, that the highest
motor senses represent over
again in more complex
combinations what
the middle motor
centers represent.
In other words, he was saying
that, the whole of the brain,
all the way up, is about
coordinating perception
with action.
And he described it in many
senses as a layered system.
He talked about how
you could take off
the top layers of the system
and the competences of the lower
layers remained intact,
which, of course, is
very much the idea of
Rodney Brooks subsumption
architecture.
And some old studies, they
did transection in animals
like cats and rats--
demonstrate this nicely.
So if you take a cat or a
rat, particularly a rat,
and you remove, in fact,
all of the cerebral cortex,
so if you make a slice here
that takes away cortex,
you get an animal that
actually, to all appearances,
looks fairly normal.
It does motivated
behavioral sequences,
so it will get hungry.
And it will look for food.
And it will eat.
If there's an
appropriate mate nearby,
it will look to have
a sexual relationship.
And it will fail in some
challenges such as learning,
and perhaps also in dexterous
control, but in many ways,
it will look normal.
If you slice below the
other part of the forebrain,
the thalamus and
the hypothalamus,
you remove these areas, then
you remove this capacity
for motivated behavior, but you
leave intact midbrain systems
that can still generate
individual actions.
And if you remove
parts of the midbrain,
you leave intact, still,
component movements,
so for example, animals
that can run on a treadmill.
So we are, with our MiRo
robot, loosely recapitulating
this architecture, so we
have three processors.
And the idea with this robot,
it's actually a part work,
so you build it up.
You get a magazine every week
with a new part for the robot.
And you build, essentially,
a spinal robot first.
And then you add a
midbrain processor.
Eventually you add a
cortical processor,
which gives with it some
learning capacities,
some pattern recognition,
some navigation, so that's
one principle, layered
architecture, which
seems to work both for biology,
and perhaps in robotics.
So second principle,
and this goes back
to another famous
neuroscientist,
this time Wilder Penfield,
who is known to many people
for his discovery of
somatotopic maps in the brain,
that if you stimulate, in
the brain, in the area,
the sensory area, then
you find that people
have experience of tickling
on parts of the body.
And adjacent parts
of cortex correspond
to adjacent parts of the body.
And he found a similar
homunculus in the motor area
that you stimulate,
and you get movement
in adjacent parts of the body.
And he also proposed
another idea.
And that was sort of a
transencephalic dimension
to nervous system organization.
And that's to say
that, down the midline
of the central
nervous system, there
are a group of structures that
don't seem to be specifically
involved in specific aspects
of perception and action,
but seem to be
about integration.
And amongst them, particularly
the basal ganglia,
he noted as being
important, and parts
of the reticular formation.
So Michael Frank was
here talking to you
about basal ganglia,
so I'm not going
to say much more about this,
but this is just to point out,
in an slice in the
rat brain, these
are the elements of the
basal ganglia, particularly,
the striatum is
the input system.
In the rat, the substantia nigra
and part of the globus pallidus
are the output systems.
And then you have, in the rat
brain, and also in our brains,
you have massive
convergence onto the input
area, the caudate putamen it
is also called, from the cortex
and from the brain stem.
So you have signals coming
in from all over the brain
to the striatum, which
could be interpreted
as a request for action.
And then you have
inhibition coming out
from the output structures
of the basal ganglia,
here I'm showing it for
the substantia nigra,
going back to all of
those areas of the brain.
And this inhibition is tonic.
And in order to have
functional reaction,
you have to remove
the inhibition.
So this is a system
that can give you
some of that
behavioral integration
that you need, the
ability to ensure that you
do one thing at a time.
You do that quickly.
You do that consistently.
You dedicate all of your
resources to the action
that you want to do.
Here's a little video of a rat.
And I'm showing you some
integrated behavior over time
in an intact rat.
So this is a rat exploring
in a large container.
And rats generally
don't like open spaces,
so when you first put the
animal into this space,
it will tend to
stay near the walls.
And it prefers this
corner, which is dark.
And of course, it's hungry too,
so there's a dish of food here.
And eventually, it
gets up the courage
to go out, collect
a piece of food,
and it will take it back into
this dark corner to consume it.
And one of the first
models that we built
was a model of basal ganglia
operating as this, kind of,
action-selection device.
And with a simple
Kepler robot, this
is a robot that just really uses
infrared sensors and a gripper
arm.
And we are using a model
of the basal ganglia
to control decision
making about which actions
to do at which time, and
to generate sequencing
of those actions.
So as the need to stay
close to walls diminishes,
the robot, like the rat, goes
and collects these cylinders.
And it carries them back into
the corners and deposits them.
So a model of the central
brain structures-- and I'm
happy to discuss in more detail
about how that model operates,
and how similarities
to the model
that Michael will
have described to you,
but that's controlling the
behavior switching, if you
like, in this robot.
So I spent some time working
on this question of how
central systems in the brain,
particularly the basal ganglia,
are involved in the
integration of behavior,
but I became frustrated
with not understanding what
were the signals coming in to
the central brain structures
and not understanding
what effects those brain
structures were having on the
motor system of the animal.
So I thought that
what we needed to do
was look at complete
sensory motor loops.
We needed to look at sensing and
action, and how those interact.
And in our Psychology
Department,
we have a neuroscience
group that
works mainly with rats,
so it was natural for us
to look at the rat.
And in the rat, we know that one
of the key perception systems
is the vertebral system.
So here you see, this
is actually a pet rat,
wandering around
on my windowsill
in my house in Sheffield.
And the thing to notice
is the whiskers here.
And the whiskers are moving
back and forth pretty
much all the time that
the rat is exploring.
And we understand from nearly
100 years now of research
that this system is very
important for the rat
to understand the environment.
In fact, if it's
completely dark,
the rat would move around
in much the same way.
And it would be
able to understand
the world through
touch pretty well, even
in the absence of vision.
So this is the same
video, but now slow down
10 times, and just to
show you these movements
of the whiskers, and how
quite precise they are,
because the rat isn't just,
in a stereotypical way,
banging its whiskers
against the floor.
It is lightly
touching the whiskers
in places it will get
useful information.
And you can see, when he puts
his head over the window sill
here, the whiskers
push forward, as
if he knows that
he's going to have
to reach further forward if
he's going to find anything.
Here you see him
exploring this wooden cup.
And you can see light
touches by the whiskers.
And you can also see that
the movement of the whiskers
is being modulated by
the shape of the surface
that he's investigating,
so there's
some fairly subtle
control happening here.
And I think it's
not too much to say
that the way in which the
rat controls its whiskers
has almost the same
richness as the way
that we control our fingertips.
So I'm interested in
how this plays out
in terms of a layered
architecture story.
And of course, many
people study this system.
The beauty of it is, if
you're a neuroscientist,
that you can look in the cortex.
This is rat cortex here.
And a huge area of rat cortex
is dedicated to somatosensation,
to touch, of which a large
area is dedicated to whiskers.
In fact, you zoom
in, you can find
this area called barrel cortex.
And with the right
kind of staining,
you can find groups of cells
which preferentially receive
signals from
individual whiskers,
so for example, you can
move one whisker here,
and you can know exactly where
you record in the barrel cortex
to get a very strong
response from that whisker.
And this means that barrel
cortex and the whisker system
has become one of the prepared,
preferred preparations in which
to study the cortical
microcircuit altogether,
so people study this
system to really understand
how cortex operates.
Now, if we think
about this system
as a pathway from the
whiskers up to barrel cortex,
we're really only
capturing one element
of what's going on in
the vertebral system.
And that's this pathway
here from the vertebrae,
via the trigeminal complex,
goes by the thalamus
up to sensory cortex.
And this is probably where 9
out of 10 papers on this system
are published, but
actually, this system
is only part of a
looped architecture,
or we might say, a
layered architecture.
And at each level of this
layered architecture,
there's a completed loop, so
that sensing can affect action,
so sensing on the vertebrae can
affect the movement and control
of the vertebrae.
So there's a loop
via the brainstem
here, so that, directly
from the trigeminal complex,
signals come back to the
facial nucleus, which
is where the motor neurons
are that move the whiskers.
There's a loop via
the midbrain here
so that sensory signals
ascend very quickly
to the midbrain
superior colliculus.
And they come back to affect
how the whiskers move.
And then, of course, there's
the loop via the cortex
too, so there's essentially
those three loops, at least,
that we need to think about.
So since 2003,
we've been building
different whiskered
robots, the aim being
to instantiate our
theories about how
whiskered control works in
this layered architecture
and demonstrate it
in a robot platform.
And often, actually,
building a robot platform
causes us to ask new
questions that might not
be obvious to you just by
doing biological experiments
or even by doing simulation.
Before I show you
some robots, just
quickly show a little bit more
about the rat and its whiskers.
So we began thinking we
could just build robots,
but we quickly
realized that we didn't
know enough about how rats
use their whiskers to do that.
And that's partly because the
experiments that had been done
haven't been done with
the purpose of building
a whiskered robot.
So when you try and
build a whiskered robot,
you have to ask questions
like, how do the whiskers move?
And when you look at a video
like this filmed from above,
this is with a
high speed camera,
you think, well, the whiskers
are sweeping backward
and forward, like this.
But in fact, if you put a
mirror just tilted down here
and you see what
happens, then it
turns out to be a
little bit different,
so you see that the whiskers
are going up and down as much
as they are going
backwards and forwards.
So the whiskers are
actually sweeping like this,
and they're making a series
of touches on the surface.
And if you watch, you can
see that the whiskers are
sort of playing down on the
surface, sort of in a sequence,
quite quickly, so that
information might be giving you
details about the shape of
the surfaces in your world.
So we mainly look at
the long whiskers.
This is a rat that's
running up an alley.
And we put an unexpected
object in the alley, which
could be this
aluminum rectangle,
or it could be
this plastic step.
And what you see is, if the
animal encounters something
unexpected with its
long whiskers, then
it turns very quickly
and investigates it.
So the long whiskers
are like the periphery
of a sensory system
that has a fovea.
And the fovea at the
center of that system
is a set of short whiskers
around the mouth, also
the lips and the
nose, so that you
can sniff and smell the surface
that you're investigating.
So we can zoom in and see
that sensory fovea, here you
see these short whiskers that
are being used to investigate
this plastic puck, and the
longer whiskers investigating
around the outside.
So we have
recapitulated elements
of this layered
architecture in our robot.
And this is-- these
are the loops.
And this was about
five years ago,
we built a system with
a brain stem loop,
and really, midbrain loop.
And this is our
robot Scratchbot,
which is the first of
the whiskered robots
that we felt really was
capturing whisking in the way
that the rat does it.
It's running at about 4
hertz, whereas the real rat is
whisking from 8 to
12 hertz, but it's
scaled up to be about
four times rat size.
And what it's
doing here is, it's
using the whiskers
to orient to stimuli,
so this is Martin Pearson
from Bristol Robotics Lab.
He's putting an object
in the whisker field.
And the robot is
turning and orienting
to the touch with the object.
It's putting its short
micro vibrissae, in fact,
against the object
and exploring it.
Now to do that, to detect
a stimulus on the whiskers
and then turn is not a
fantastically hard task.
The main challenge
is to work out
where the whisker
was in its sweep
when you made contact
with an object,
because the whisker is
sweeping back and forth,
so if you want to
know the location
of the point of
contact, you need
to integrate the position of the
whisker in its sweep, what you
might call a theta
signal, and the presence
of the contact on the whiskers.
And the coincidence of those
two is detected in the brain.
And we know that there are
cells in the barrel cortex
that respond to
that coincidence.
So we have in our robot a model
of the super colliculus, which
is the location in
the brain which we
think is involved in orienting.
And in our model
of the colliculus,
we have a head-centered
map, which
looks for this coincidence
between a cell encoding
the position of the whisker
in its sweep and a cell
encoding a contact and makes
a turn to orient and explore
that position.
And then if we want
to actually create
behavior, which is
integrated over time,
so if the robot was just to
orient every time it touched
something, that wouldn't
be very animal-like,
particularly, you
don't want to orient
every time you touch
the ground, so you just
want to orient when you
touch important stimuli.
So we put into our
model the basal ganglia
so that we can decide whether
the contact we've just made
is something we
want to investigate
or something that doesn't
interest us so much.
So we have a system
now with a midbrain
that does orienting, a basal
ganglia that makes decisions
about sequencing.
And those two things
together give us
reasonably lifelike behavior
in our robot, Scratchbot.
And that's quite
a lot of what we
have running now on the new
robot, MiRo, is this system.
It's for orienting
and exploring.
And we can use it-- we use it
here for tactile orienting,
but of course, the
same system can
underlie orienting
to sounds, if you
can localize those, and space,
and orienting to visual stimuli
too.
So it turns out that this
isn't a complete solution
to the problem of orienting
for our whiskered robot.
And that's because
sometimes our robot
would stop as it
was moving around
and just move and
investigate a point in space
where nothing was happening.
We call that a ghost orient.
And the problem is
that the whiskers,
because they're
moving back and forth,
they sometimes generate
signals in the strain
gauges that are detecting
bending of the whisker.
And sometimes those
signals, just as
a consequence of the movement
and the mass of the whisker,
are strong enough to
be above threshold
to generate an
orient, so you get,
if you like, these
ghost-orienting movements
towards stimuli
that don't exist.
And we know that rats don't make
these kind of ghost orients,
so something else must
be going on in the brain.
And one part of the brain
that might be helping here
is a region called the
cerebellum, which, I'm not sure
if you've covered that
in the summer school,
but the cerebellum,
this large structure
at the back of the right brain.
One of its key
functions seems to be
to make predictions
about sensory signals,
and particularly, to be able
to predict sensory signals that
have been caused by
your own movement.
And there's a lovely
experiment that's
been done by Blakemore et
al, where they put people
into a scanner.
And they investigated how they
responded to tickling stimuli.
So of course, if
somebody tickles you,
that can be quite amusing,
but unfortunately,
if you try to tickle yourself,
it's really uninteresting.
It doesn't work as a stimulus.
And it's worth thinking about
why it is that self-tickling
is so unrewarding.
And one of the reasons is
that it's just not surprising.
You know what's going to happen
when you tickle yourself,
whereas if somebody
else is doing it,
it's unexpected and surprising.
So why is self-tickling
unexpected?
Why is it not surprising?
It must be because the brain
expects and anticipates
the signal that
it's going to get.
And what Blakemore
et al did was to show
that the cerebellum
really lights up
when you try to tickle
yourself, because it's
estimating and predicting
the sensory signal,
and using that to
cancel out, if you like,
the signal that's
coming from your skin.
The same thing is happening
in electric fish, which
generate this broad
electric field which
they use for catching prey.
And they need to be able
to tell the difference
between a distortion to the
electric field caused by a prey
animal and a distortion
caused by their own movement,
by swimming.
And they do that by having
a very large cerebellum.
So we put a model
of the cerebellum
in our whiskered robot.
And the cerebellum
predicts the noise
you might get due to the
movement of the whiskers.
And it learns
online to accurately
predict what noise
signals you might get,
and to cancel them
out, so you get
a much better signal-to-noise
ratio in the robot.
So we've dealt with whisking.
And we've dealt with orienting.
But as you saw with that
rat on the windowsill,
the whisker movements
are really precise.
And they're really controlled.
And the rat seems
to really care about
how it's moving its whiskers
and how it's touching.
We call this active sensing.
And if you look at
these high-speed videos,
you can see, for
instance, this rat
when it's exploring
this perspex block.
The whiskers aren't moving in
a stereotype symmetric way.
You can see that here, the
whiskers on the right-hand side
are really reaching
round to try and reach
the other side of the block.
If you watch this rat
here, you see that too.
You've got asymmetry.
And you'll see that, even as
the rat comes up to the cylinder
here, the whiskers at the
front are pushing forward
while the ones at the back
are hardly moving at all,
so there's some ability to
control even the whiskers
on one side of the head.
And when you move your
fingers, of course,
there's some coupling between
your finger movements.
You can't move them
entirely independently.
And each of these whiskers
has its own muscle,
so there's a degree
of independence
in how the whiskers can move.
And we find that when we
record over long intervals.
So this was a study--
[ELECTRONIC NOISE]
--in which we recorded the
whisking muscles using EMG.
And that's the sound that you
can hear as the rat explored.
And we tracked the rat
as he was moving around.
And we showed that,
whenever he came
close to the edge
of the box here,
the whiskers would
become asymmetric.
And the whiskers that were
furthest away from the wall
would push round to try and
touch the sides of the box.
The whiskers that
were close to the wall
would barely move at all.
So we want to put that kind
of control into our robot.
So I briefly want to come
back to this question of how
we decompose control.
So in our original robot
that was controlled
by the basal ganglia,
and it's collecting cans,
we decompose behaviors
into the different elements
of behavior--
looking for a can, picking it
up, carrying it to the wall,
these sorts of things.
And if we look in the
ethology literature,
we find that people have
talked about these kinds
of decompositions.
There's a very famous
paper by Baerends
about the herring gull.
And with the herring
gull, there's
this famous experiment where
the egg rolls out the nest.
And the bird will retrieve
the egg with its bill
and push it back into the nest.
And it will do this same action
really reliably and repeatedly.
And it can do it with
eggs of various size.
It might even do
it for a Coke can.
And if you take the egg
away during the movement,
it will still
complete the movement.
And ethologists have called
this a fixed action pattern,
so it may be that
behavior is decomposed
into action patterns.
And that's one of the
ways, for instance,
in which Rodney Brooks wants
to decompose robot behavior.
We decompose it into
different things
we might want the robot to do.
And we can do that with
our whiskered robots.
Here's another one with
its behavior decomposed
into different kinds
of, if you like,
orienting behaviors and
fixed action patterns.
Another way to
decompose behavior
is to think about where
your attention is, so
where you put your
attention might decide
what you're going to do next.
And for an animal that
doesn't have arms,
and of course most animals
except humans and some primates
don't usually use their
forelimbs for much else
other than locomotion.
And they primarily
are positioning
their head and their face.
And their main effector,
then, is their mouth.
So where you position
your attention
could determine what
you're going to do next.
So another way of
decomposing control
is to solve the
attention problem first.
And then once you
solve that, the problem
of what you're going
to do is simplified.
So in this robot,
we're controlling it
by deciding where its
attention should go.
And then the rest of the
body kind of follows.
When humans have special
attention, of course,
we explore that in
the visual modality.
And we look at the saccadic
eye movements that people make.
So in the famous
experiment, Albert Yarbus
had people looking
at this picture
and tracking where
their eyes would look.
And of course, we look at the
socially-significant elements
of the picture, people's
faces and so on,
not just arbitrary points of
light, or corners, and so on.
And we can actually calculate
a saliency map for space
and say what are the
important parts of space
for exploring and attending to.
And we've taken that idea and
transferred it into our model
for understanding the rat.
And we thought about tactile
saliency maps, so can
we, with a sense of
touch, think about areas
of the world which are important
to explore and understand
through touch?
And can we use that to
control the movement
of our robot, or in this
case, our simulation?
So here, we have a form of
emergent wall following, which
is a consequence of the
rat's spatial attention being
driven by contact with
vertical objects, which we--
we program it so that
the vertical surfaces
are salient and interesting.
And it has this salient zone.
And it tries to put its
whiskers into the salient zone.
And then here is a robot
instantiating this.
This is Ben Mitchinson,
who's programmed
many of these robots.
And so what we're
doing now is following
this biologically-inspired
orienting system
to explore shapes.
And in this case, he put his
own face in front of the robot.
And you can see the robot making
light touches against his face
and investigating it, looking--
making a series of, if you
like, exploratory touches,
somewhat like saccades,
somewhat like what
you might imagine a
blind person would
do if they were
investigating your face
to try and recognize you.
And Mitra Hartmann
from Northwestern
has shown that you
can take signals
off these kinds of whiskers
and reconstruct a face,
so it should be
possible from this
to build up from the touches,
the sequence of touches,
a lot of rich information
about the object that's
being investigated.
How much time?
I need to finish.
OK, let me just skip through.
So we've been doing--
working on the cortex.
We have a number
of models of that,
which I'd like to
show you, but I
want to just finish,
just to make contact
with John's talk, is
that we've been doing,
in our robots, tactile
simultaneous localization
and mapping.
So this is our whiskered robot.
And we have various models
for this, some of which
are more hippocampal-like.
This one, I think, was more
of an engineered model.
But you can see the
robot just using touch
on these artificial
whiskers, building up
a map of its environment.
These two lines show its
dead-reckoning position
and its calculated position.
And just using touch,
we can build up
a reasonably accurate map of
the world that we're exploring.
So Giorgio will
talk about the iCub.
And I just wanted to mention
that, in the work we're
doing with Giorgio, we
are very much trying
to understand human cognition.
I wrote a short article for New
Scientist on the possibility
that robots might
one day have selves.